my channel is sponsored by factor which
means we will have an ad from them in a
couple of minutes but also before we get
into this episode of red lips orange car
i wanted to let you know that this
podcast and every other podcast on my
channel is supported by the wonderful
people on patreon supporters on patreon
not only help me make these shows pay
hosts pay an editor pay artists and more
but patreon supporters also get extra
content they get completely unedited
versions of red lips orange car plus add
free versions of every show i make so if
you want to support head to patreon.com
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of red lips orange car i'm alana
that that's charlotte that's fiona we do
not have a token
straight man this episode because we
really just had to scramble to make the
time work
we're devastated um that that
underrepresented
yes
that that underrepresented demographic
is not present
for this episode we really the future is
female and so is the podcast
tonight it's true today that is true
whenever you're listening um question
i have this misconnection this is from
new york
it says
yeah headline
missing connection just between me
let's meet and play oh
what does that mean
okay
miss connection just between me just
between me
let's meet and let's meet and play so is
is this person missing something
a piece of themselves
missed missing connection just between
me and then w in brackets implying that
it is a woman oh and you've sent it i
did let's meet
and play posted about an hour ago what
does it mean
just in between um between me
just between me so here's a fun thing
let's meet and play do you guys know
about doppel banging
oh is that like finding something that
looks like you will try to save people
who like themselves oh it happens all
the time lesbians do this all the time
which i'd love to know do you think it's
a narcissist thing
uh or yeah you have to kind of look at
what the field looks like because i if i
could tell you all the trans lesbians
with colorful hair and that doesn't mean
you look alive not not look like i'm
telling i'm talking about like cara
delevingne and ashley benson
i'm talking like oh okay
that doppel banging like siblings
originated from the queer community and
refers to a person to when a person
dates someone who looks similar to them
huh i think it's funnier in the straight
community
oh yeah that's like a woman
finding a girl a girlish man you guys
see that that instagram siblings are
dating yeah siblings are dating that's
like yeah that was incredible you know
yeah i'm i i heard this ones and it and
the pictures did back it up but uh
phineas eilish yeah was dating someone
who looked up quite a bit like billy for
a moment oh i don't like it but
i think her hair changed oh and
everything's cool but what is it i'd
love to know the mentality
here's the thing the mentality of that
because i could never date someone who
looks like me because i hate myself
which
most people do
yeah
so most people hate the owner that's not
i don't know oh great really i'm called
oh my god
argue about that 100 percent oh shut up
you're absolutely i
i don't know where you live but i'll
figure it out
all right let's do it she lives in the
hollywood sign
she's working in shelby
right up on the 8th
but also i also could never date
somebody who looks like me
um i don't know what it means i mean
that siblings are dating
instagram
yeah
it is constant content and it's good
content what does it mean yeah what does
it mean does it mean that you're
obsessed with yourself or are you just
comfortable with yourself so that's why
you go with someone who looks like you
i just want to say that i would date
someone that looks like me
now
now i'd love to deep dive into that it's
unpacked very attractive i'm very
attracted to myself well that makes
sense i'm a big fan of charlotte
uh
i i think so it's is it a more popular
yeah i just like looking at my
reflection and it would be easy to have
that like mobile well i guess you could
get a pocket mirror you can also date
yourself i think there are stories of
people doing that like being in
committed really well i'm not going to
do that i can't stand myself
i'm talking about looks oh
i i could not date charlotte
looking at her though
yeah all right
i'm very superficially narcissistic
it is time to talk about factor my
absolute favorite thing about factor is
that it saves time and alleviates stress
there is no prep
no mess and you get fresh never frozen
meals factor completely cuts out
stressful meal planning and extensive
prepping you just pick your meals from a
new menu of 29 plus dietitian design
options every week their gourmet chefs
cook them to perfection they are
delivered to your home and you heat them
and eat them it takes the guesswork out
of what to make for breakfast lunch or
dinner and offers meals that are
specific to your diet fact it makes it
possible for you to achieve your daily
goals for nutritious purposeful eating
you are straight up not going to want
takeout anymore because factor basically
does the same thing for you but better
factor helps you avoid fast food and
ordering in with no-nonsense delicious
food that's ready quickly meals arrived
pre-prepared and ready to eat in two
minutes or less even faster than
ordering in also on top of the rotating
weekly menu there are 33 additional
add-ons like smoothies keto shakes
desserts and more factor has plenty of
variety so you can find meals that you
like and again my absolute favorite
thing about it is that i so often don't
even have time to make lunch i'll get to
6 p.m and realize that i haven't eaten
lunch i just didn't have time to put
something together facta completely
fixed that for me as soon as they sent
my meals i realized that i had had a
whole week without getting to the end of
the day overly hungry factor suits my
lifestyle so so so well and i'm sure
that that will apply to a whole lot of
youtube so use my link or go to
gofacta75.com and use code pog alana 120
for 120
off
okay there's an ny post article about
doppel banging for people who date
people who look like that yeah
okay um
it's a trendy phenomenon of duffel
bangers among celebrity couples who have
uncanny mirroring features cosmopolitan
reported okay but what's the science i'd
love to know the psychology of it
because i i can't do it
norwegian scientists
oh
your favorite charlotte yeah i love it
you love them they're your favorite
songs
they are your favorite scientists i
can't get enough of these norwegians
like the finnish scientists
no that played out no norwegians worked
out okay they're finished norwegian
scientists at the universities of oslo
and
trum but the oh has like a
like a tom oh like that
i don't know what this word is
conducted a 2013 story study where test
subjects were shown alterations to their
partner's face and asked to determine
which variety they found to be the most
appealing
participants distinctly preferred a
self-based morph
i.e their partner's face with a small
amount of their self's face
into it of course as as norwegian
scientists fan you'd be familiar with
the concept
so they were literally testing people
who were their partners and then they
morphed their own faces onto their
partners and these people were picking
the ones that looked more like them
that's so i have a funny anecdote that i
think is pertinent what's that uh
years ago uh when i was a younger woman
in my early 20s i was dating someone and
i was uh
basically like pre-transition so i did
not know how to do makeup and so she did
it for me and at the time this is the
woman i was dating and at the time it
was incredible it was like
a life-altering
like moment for me yeah i went back and
looked at the photo recently and i
almost dropped my phone because she did
make up very well but she just did one
face right and so she basically put her
face on me and i looked at the photo and
i went
oh my god that's my ex
it was a selfie but i was like holy [ __ ]
yeah i it was like a really because it
was like her face and at the time i
didn't realize it just through the
euphoria i was just like wow cool this
is awesome but like
like it was like muscle memory it was
like a spider's web being spun on my
face
it was so strange it was really
uncertain i've not done a lot of makeup
on other people but i feel like
i would just do the same [ __ ] then i
would do your routine yeah i would do
the same
which sam
it's yeah i can understand that a thing
that's also terrible very very strange
to come i wonder what the norwegian
scientists would have to say about that
i'm sure a lot
oh my god yeah what what
what could sven say
everybody's favorite
a 2008 study in hungary found by
the
mail
what is this is it's found by the mail
indicating that the daily mail found the
study
or the study was done by the mail mail
i don't understand it needs to be noted
that it was done by a male found by the
male yes a man
though on the team it was it was like
this podcast last week the man exactly
um indicated that many seek a partner
who resembles a family member women were
found to be inclined to men whose faces
looked like their own fathers
and just as dr melfi of course often
debated with tony soprano on the
fictional hbo series what the [ __ ] is
this article in my post
to have relationships with women who
resemble their mothers i mean that's a
thing that's been
what a year has been said for a while
this is like 2002 2008 yeah
skipping over oedipus let's go straight
into freud for dr melfi
it appears that a once believed theory
that married couples begin to look alike
after years together which came from the
university of michigan in 1987
was
the university of michigan in norway
was debunked in 2020 why did that take
so long to debunk yeah right well i
guess not enough money was put in there
it took 23 years
jesus christ
one male puzzling over yes
in any case not sure what missing
connection just between me w let's meet
and play means
no but a lot of information about doppel
banging yeah charlotte
no i just i just i think it's something
you can repeat to yourself missing
connection just between me and me
let's meet damn that is that's a good
thing
mom's question
mom
think about it true you're right my
little lyric yeah write that down let's
put the keyboard on missing oh yeah
connection
c-o-n-n-e-c-t i-o-n
yeah just between me
there it is let's meet and play
nice
smooth jazz that whenever i hear that
kind of smooth jazz
i always want to like pretend to be a
drunk like woman on the microphone who's
like and that's my friend benny
he's a magician on them
but there is something very funny about
like a live band at vegas or whatever
with a very clearly alcoholic lead
vocalist who's really trying to keep it
together
well one of my favorite broad city bits
was abby when she got blackout drunk
would become a jazz singer in an
underground club good with like a
completely different bombastic jazzy
persona and i can't remember the
character's name but it was like
everyone yelled it when she came in
it doesn't matter
it's her persona and everyone goes like
belle yeah and she puts on like a derby
cap it's just like
hello ladies and gentlemen val's here
for a night
that's amazing
yeah very smoky sultry stop telling
people about that shut up oh sorry sorry
[ __ ] sake what's that nothing nothing
nobody said anything blow the lid off
nothing okay we have another one um from
new york that is looking for right f
queens
hi
i'm off this morning i am tall green
eyes m50 you are free fun f
and then it has a poem
oh no
last night i slept and when i woke her
kiss still floated on my lips for we had
strayed together in my dream through
some dim glade where the shy moon beams
scarce dead light out bliss
the air was dank with you between the
trees the hidden glow worms kindled and
were spent are you guys turned on is it
working yet no
glow worms
cheek press to cheek the cool the hot
night breeze mingled our hair our breath
and came and went as sporting with our
passion
but do men think that this works now
here's what blowing what's blowing me
away is that he couldn't properly write
a sentence in the title i think this
wrote a full poem i think this poem is
stolen there is no way this this is the
same
a dim gland glade
also when i heard cheek to cheek i
immediately pictured like but
it fits oh it fits the yeah it does we
rolled it out it fits because it got too
hot and now our butts are touching low
and deep spake in mine ear her voice
and it's down dream this could be buried
this could be sleep and love betrayal to
death nay whatsoem have faith dear heart
this is the thing that is there on i
woke and on my lips
her kiss
oh
wow
did they did he say he wrote this no and
again he definitely did not so
so not claiming at least well no because
i mean the guy again the person i'm
assuming guy but like the person it is
a male a 50 year old man told he he is
tall green eyes he is tall green eyes
like you couldn't properly write a
sentence so i doubt that that was free
fun if
and this isn't gonna be a generalization
but if i can go the rest of my life
without
talking to a 50 year old
man i think that would be good i think
that's okay no i think that's fine i
think you'll be okay yeah i think that's
fine which means that what male friends
i do have i'm gonna have to kill them
forty nine
forty nine
yeah the charlotte disposal friendship
program they just start spouting poems
the minute they hit fiddy it's not worth
it you gotta get rid of it yeah you
gotta cut them out yeah i know
speaking of things that are aren't um 50
year old
tall green eyes am
um fiona yes
you
not a 50 year old tall green ice man no
but you did just join a dating assistant
as you would oh
how's it going like two day period oh we
get some details and back well so what
happens is my
when i go on on to hit i use hinge
um and what happens is i can only be
there for three to four days until i
start it starts sucking the life out of
me yes um i hate myself so you're you're
you're you're you're you're injured
right now you all though
right now i'm on but for a very short
amount of time it's gonna be probably 48
hours because what i like to do is i
like to speed through the process i buy
premium
i buy i put in money what does buying
premium do so what i what in hinge what
happens is like if you buy like the
membership or the preferred or whatever
it's called i don't know what it's
called but you can see your likes
you can get like
standouts or something it's like like
people who have engaged with you right
yes because it's not like tinder where
you swipe it's like people like your
pictures it's more like a social media
app right
and so yeah so you can see if people
like your pictures you can start a
conversation if you like each other's
pictures then you can start a
conversation you can start chatting
so what i do is i like to pay money so i
don't have to stay on
for literally more than 48 hours i
respect it so what i do is lighting
mass
what
you're expecting the process it's like
getting extra for shipping yeah yeah
exactly
i like to expedite the hinge process
[ __ ]
yeah yeah so i'm like i like that i got
i get all the likes
no no one said that stop coming on other
podcasts to show your [ __ ] did you
say podcast charlotte jesus
no one said that it's not funny oh my
god
cut it cut it she can't be stopped
okay so you speed date via a dating app
yeah then i probably start at the end of
like my three day um binge
binge of hinge nice
yeah oh binge that's so good
yeah that's good that's good
so i might really binge at the end of it
i probably have about two to three
people that i'm talking to at that point
i asked them please can we talk on
instagram instead because
i
but that's when they start seeing what i
do which is why i need to like test run
for a little bit because i don't want
them to yeah well also i just don't want
them to like i don't know how to explain
what i do without them being like
without 50 other questions yes and then
it becomes an interview
then then i'm in an interview and i
don't want to deal with it so
so i talk to them i see if i like them
or not if i want to go on a date with
them and then i'm like okay let's talk
on instagram and that's when the
relationship why not do like a whatsapp
or something
uh well whatsapp is just for my european
family i refuse to use it in the states
i don't use it either but i mean like
what if you were to use it for girls to
avoid instagram
because they're gonna find out
eventually though they're gonna find out
and then also the other thing is like it
is kind of a flex right
yeah
at least it starts a conversation
yeah of some sort they'll be definitely
more impressed by you yes and sometimes
i need a little i need a little bit of
impr i need to impress because it's so
boring otherwise because or else i have
nothing else to give two days is the
amount of conversation you can sustain
and then that's literally it and then
it's not true
i have nothing to sit by and watch you
be unkind to yourself oh you got us
listen okay that's why i'm going to
therapy
we love you guys everyone go to there
but yeah so i'm so i just downloaded it
two hours ago
um i'm gonna start doing it but i do
have a date tomorrow so i'm you know
depending on how the date goes tomorrow
i might just delete it what are you
doing on this date but diet uh yeah
we're gonna go um i actually don't
really know what we're gonna do but i
know we're gonna go eat something love
that and then i said she's coming back
to my place now here's a kicker
i need to clean my place up
before i agree
a roomba i see in the background huh
do i see a roomba that is a roomba that
got stuck oh yeah
that's stupid
i have not moved you're absolutely
correct because i have no no no no no
that big [ __ ] dummy got stuck in the
beeping
and then i begged it to die
here's what you gotta do yeah you gotta
get roomba premium
right remember expedite expedite
expedite expedition they send a hundred
roombas to you and it expedites
[Laughter]
it's like watching a vibration of crabs
now imagine all 50 roombas beeping at
the same time
it's like
that guy's apartment it's like the guy's
poem that's a good poem incredible
yeah last night i slept and when i woke
her kiss think about it is it this is
what makes a good
it's
no it's actually under new york queens
community activity partners
is the craigslist
activity partners what else is in
activity partners at the zoo
cheetah to be made to cougar do you have
an opening
oh my god
it's this is again activity partners
this one's m for f so a man wrote it for
a female
and it says wait
cheetah to be mated to a cougar do you
have an opening
so they're doing a little joke right
they're having fun with the the idea
that the the activity is for the
i think they are trying not to say
that they're a young dude who would like
to [ __ ] an older woman yeah and this is
that a cheetah code it's all code well
it's like a cheat they talked about
cougars so i'm assuming the cheetah is
the younger that's what i'm thinking
faster definitely yeah what is a cheetah
faster definitely
looking for a beautiful woman to outrun
yeah
[Laughter]
oh no looking for a beautiful older
woman to be a lot faster than to to be
faster than so funny
so it isn't necessarily sexual it could
be just be i just want a race i just
want a race babe to race
looking for you looking for a race let's
meet up after that
looking for an absolute smoke show to
show up on the track yeah
yeah bring your night bring your nikes
bring your nikes no adidas okay there's
a lot of adidas the next one immediately
also new york queen's community activity
partners is valerian steel
no but my high medial sword could use a
new sheath
oh my gosh okay
sex
sex that must be i just assume
everything sucks but this is funny hang
on let me send it to you
in the chats in the chat and then it
says
women of a certain age should drop me a
line it might be worth at least a giggle
or two what does that mean
i don't want to lose the formatting here
women of a certain age is italicized it
is it's italicized it is i feel like
that holds weight
women of a certain age i don't
understand any of these
valerian steel
high amino
hymenol hymen surely that's not a word
so valerian steel that's
um a game of thrones reference
oh right
i guess i mean i don't know it is over
concerning marriage it's what
valerian steals concerning marriage a
game of thrones reference
but he spelled it wrong
i'm an officer
valeria
hyman's role oh no i'm in i'm in
something else
i don't know where you are but if you
want to if you want to link it i'll join
you wrote a menial sword and the the
he's like okay he's definitely talking
about his dick that part but why easy we
get why go through the effort to hide it
when we know what you're talking about
it's
that me too
oh i didn't even imagine i'd like to
laugh at his weird sword dick yeah
you're right it could be younger this
could be a full pedophile dick
just maybe that's what he was trying to
say i was assuming he was trying to
attract notes but actually he's like
dude it's just really pointy i just need
you to know
that's crazy
yeah
bring over some parchment paper
rice paper maybe i don't know
i i don't know if it's just so funny
clearly looking for other weirdos and i
hope you find that yeah
nice way i want you to find them yeah
activity partners
activity partners walking partner also
queens
older gentlemen looking for younger male
walking partner enjoys getting outdoors
for that brisk walk to catch the sun
this is for walking only i don't think
so it says there's two of them but fiona
it says this is for walking only
so what else could it be for and then it
says reply with more than just a couple
of words tell me about you age etc
looking for 25 to 45
do not contact me with unsolicited
services or offers or you will be
reported this could be wholesome
i wish i was a 25 to 45 year old man to
go only walking
with this older gentleman
brisk walk to catch the sun why would
you write this if that wasn't the case
i just don't know is a brisk walk could
that be code for something but it says
walking only
yeah it's walking code yeah walking only
up the stairs to have sex upstairs and
in in keep going
no i think i'm big
but i think i think i reached whatever
that wasn't good with that yeah
yeah
this is so wild to me like this is
another one like it's large collection
of cds
seeking a like-minded guy who has a
decent stereo and cd collection i have
eclectic taste but i will i will come to
you only
how did you end up on 2003 craigslist
i'm just like but i'm like what so you
write that in a craigslist to find a
stereo
to listen to music but they won't
it's like i will only come to you it has
to be well
large collection of cds
large collection of
[ __ ] dildos probably okay
cockroach huge collection large
collection of coffee of [ __ ] rings
cocktains
cocktains what can you read it again
um
hold on i i
probably exited out large collection of
cds
seeking a like-minded guy who has a
decent stereo and cd collection i have
eclectic taste i will come to you only
i'm wondering if cd sexual is um
stds oh
no stereo is dick lodge dick for sure
maybe cds is stds bug
chases have you not have did i not talk
to you about this last time i've heard
about this
but no
a cd to be inserted into a stereo
cds with a big scenario
are we maybe overthinking the
the eloquence but he says he has
eclectic taste so are you telling me as
multiple types of stds
yeah okay so bug chasing fiona if you're
not familiar is the practice of
intentionally seeking human
immunodeficiency virus like hiv
infection through sexual activity there
are people who do bug chasing who
intentionally like yeah trying to catch
hiv or aids is one of them but try to
catch as many stds as they can that is
uh the only kink i'm okay with shaming
king
bug chases on men who have sex with men
who who eroticize hiv infection
especially through the intentional
pursuit of infection with the virus
little is understood about the practice
in general motivations for developing
bug-chasing identity and behavior remain
largely undefined but there are four
common motivating explanations first
fear of hiv infection has previously
altered their sexual behavior such as
having them abstain from sex entirely
so bug chasing is viewed as empowering
because they're like [ __ ] it if i get
hiv
i don't care it's done
um
and then some men view hiv positive
status as erotic or sexually stimulating
third bug chasers may understand hiv
positive status as granting a shared
identity and sense of community
fourth bug chasing and discord
just don't you want a sense of community
just join a discord don't dive from aids
what is going on
just join a discord bro there's so many
communities
there's a discord for it
and it
probably overlaps with a specific games
community i'm not even trying to call
out anything i'm just saying you know
that there's a there's a venn diagram
but also i can't help but wonder like
how like
prevalent this could possibly be and how
much of it is spread due to like a
deeply ingrained homophobia yeah like
like it's gotta get legs from people
that are like see that this is what
they're like this is like what they're
into oh yeah for sure i'm not saying it
doesn't exist but i see what you mean
it's probably it could be like it it's
probably it's i mean obviously very very
niche it's it says that it's so niche
that they have a little research on it
there's very little info but yeah it's
it yeah the fact that anyone knows about
it means it's probably over reported
yeah because it's convenient you're
right you know yeah because it would
largely be yeah it's convenient it's
probably it's just like oh yeah well you
can't have gay men preparing each other
because they're bug chasers or whatever
so i'm like i'm like to even imagine
that to be a thing like if someone told
me that i'd be like you're lying
the bug chasing in general the truth
yeah like you're not why are you that
that doesn't make any sense there is one
journalist who conducted some interviews
with some bug chasers and it says this
is a quote i'm not saying i don't think
it's real oh yeah it's gotta be just
very minimal once the initial shock
dissipated he felt relieved like he had
been given a free pass to have
consensual bareback sex without worry of
being infected it's like when you get
covert
and you yeah right you get tired and
then you're free and then
and then you feel bad for a week and and
yeah no
no it's not similar at all no
you feel free for three months maybe
no having covered was not great yeah oh
no it sucked coveted sucks yeah that was
not fun no i did feel like i could go to
things for two months and not me too get
sick again which was nice i did yeah but
then once the two months was over i got
scared i'm going to pax and that's my
lost one and is getting outside that
immunity window so i am mosque enough
yeah i'm going there too and i'm
terrified i was like i told my because
like g4 is going so all my co-workers
are going and i'm like guys i'll be
honest uh i don't think we're doing this
show the week after because we're all
gonna get copied like i don't know why
you think we're not i'm gonna be so
careful that people are gonna think i'm
an [ __ ] and i'm okay with it like i'm
just gonna like anyone tries to touch me
i'll be like
no yeah
all right bye sorry about that
i got it
i gotta tell you guys i am i'm addicted
to these bad boys these rapid tests
we got a bunch of them at work and i i
have uh a couple things going on i have
allergies i have acid reflux and i have
a hell of a lot of anxiety and so i have
like basically a constant sore throat
yeah and
anxiety
exacerbates it so like i'm like always
doing rapid tests like just like
constantly doing rapid tests so i've
been having this weird thing happen at
work um so i got covered
um in january
and so i got in january and i had my
three months and now my three months is
basically kind of over right
um and
my three months is over and
a month ago i get tested for positive
like tested positive again and i'm like
oh that's that's a little weird since
it's just i mean it's still not really
three months but okay fine i'm positive
but then i did another pcr and it was
negative oh you think you got a pcr came
back positive positive so my pcr came
back uh positive then the day after i
took another pcr test and i get tested
every week pcr test every week i got
took another one it was negative so i
was like okay i need to take another one
to make sure and it was negative so it
was a false positive
last week i got another false positive
and i was like
this is terrifying that is scary
because then they're not dependable
it's because then i'm like then what's
the truth because i got and it was all
pcr it's like spit
um the
akula or whatever like but like the
literal pcr test and i was getting false
positives and i was like were you doing
it at home once
no it was at like an office
like with covid officers and everything
that's concerned and it happened yeah
twice in a month false positive and uh
and this isn't even like right after i
got
coveted in january this is three months
after i hate that a lot i hated that i
was like guys what is the implications
that are concerning and i don't know
what happened i don't have it but it was
like that's weird why am i getting false
positives now if it happened during the
three months i would would have made
sense
because you can
you can keep testing positive three
months
wait has it been three months since
january yeah oh my god yeah it's april
[ __ ] it's april it's time we out
here really wasting this year my god
forgot about it
you know it's been yeah
my life is just being wasted so it's
it's not new to me um you know what's
been weird to watch is like one
company in particular one testing
company gain profits
and like you know they had a they
clearly went through a tough time when
during hot vac summer when people didn't
need tests as much
yeah and then they started at offering
like b12 shots and like uh all sorts of
different injections and like wellness
stuff and then when it came back with a
forest with delta
now they're driving teslas they have
beautiful brick and mortar locations
they have
staffed up like crazy and it's like man
this sucks
yeah why are you driving a tesla
the fact that so many companies have
pivoted to like
and they employ such large forces makes
me think the testing won't go away it's
too
profitable for two profitable
i guess i'm just not knowledgeable about
it but is there like um a license
or a um thing like kind of how
lifeguarding you have to go through a
thing to like become a lifeguard to get
your like certification
can you get a certification to become a
covent officer like i guess someone who
tests for me
because they're not nurses i don't know
i don't think there's a standardization
yeah i don't think so
interesting
um in any case
yeah i just found two uh again new york
listings um clearly written by the same
person um yeah very bizarrely the first
one
is
eating out face sitting queening [ __ ]
eating
nyc however that's me sorry that's
however sorry
sitting the i is a one
i don't know what queening means and
then [ __ ] is spelled p u 5.5y
i see this why
so i'm assuming
i'm i'm assuming maybe um they think
it'll get flagged craigslist but it
doesn't craigslist will flag even though
right under its lf dirty girls 18 and
20. it doesn't get flagged
is it all in caps no um no it goes on to
say i love to zero r dot at l y p l at
show a woman you're gonna you're gonna
have to read it out for me i don't know
what that would say
pleasure
which is actually very nice this is
actually a very nice listing i love to
orally pleasure a woman in any in every
way she wants for as long as she can
stand it if you're looking for this kind
of pleasure drop a line no strings no
reciprocation nothing else needed trust
your aura pleasure anyway you want
i love to eat
eat
it's very polite but also wow did you
why why
why yeah i think it's i think it's just
common practice to do this kind of like
simple code do you think right like to
not do it to try to attract people with
leaked talk
gamers gaming bro there's a discord i'm
sure
age plays also
why is so many of them censoring
themselves
i sent one in the chat um that i saw
which i got i got a little confused
about okay yeah go ahead
um
okay i see old older m for older f for
extra
marital congress congress
want to know more
a cordial reply will get you a page full
of information that can't fit on here
thank you
so yeah they're turning yeah but why is
he being so fancy about it it's so weird
because he's an old weirdo
again murder them all when they turn 49.
when they're 49.
call the herd the guillotine
i mean this is like a this is like a
weirdo guy who's decided like perhaps
perchance it'd be time to find pleasure
outside my lady
yeah and i think it's normal to talk
like this
are either of you i i occasionally post
um screenshots of things on my close
friends on instagram
and i recently did one
of this dude who only ever speaks in the
most formal language yeah
while trying to hit on me yes yes yes
yes yes kind of kind of unfortunately so
funny
nuts it is so uncomfortable to read it's
like vow and [ __ ]
and like i don't know that really thinks
he's gonna get me
on this
alana there's something about your
unrequested dms that i would love to
just scroll through two minutes
i have done that i don't think i would
on videos before
and they're mostly nice but they're
they're yeah there are some strange ones
because i bet there's some gold in there
that i just i know you get and no one
else gets
and i just oh my god yeah yeah
i sent patrick mine
the my the like weird ones that i get
because there are some
you know this is a fun thing but a lot
of people tend to fetishize trans women
yes oh yeah i can only imagine
i still think this is one of my favorite
messages i've ever received and this is
like actually pretty serious but the
absurdity of this
um yeah this is a person i never spoke
to never spoke to yes
outside from when he showed up in person
at things
but other than that cool okay liked your
last tweet i have a recurring question
about our relationship it's focused on
the realism of our relationship
the la comic-con replying about not
posting when you're djing got me
doubting as well as you're dating
someone comment on youtube video when i
think dating i think one that goes on
dates in the real world this is where it
gets more interesting
you ignoring me and calling the cops on
me are also big factors
maybe it's the new anti-delusion meds
that i'm on that's giving me perspective
on our past let me know
pal they're not working
this is a dude who thought that we were
in a relationship for five years and
would on often send me angry messages
about how i was being a shitty
girlfriend because i wasn't responding
to him he thought all of my tweets were
directed at him and found ways to make
them about him
and he would look at whatever i was
listening to on spotify which i didn't
even know is a thing that you could do
um
and then email me about what i was
listening to on spotify and i didn't i
mean i didn't even know this was
happening because it was this email
address i didn't use until i happened to
log in one day and i found like 400
emails and i was like holy [ __ ] this
one's an xbox live message but oh my god
the fact that somebody messaged me
because i banned his email the phrase
you ignoring me and calling the cops on
me are also big factors when you ever
call the cops yes because he was
actually
like actively stalking me showing up in
person [ __ ]
that's crazy and he was like i think
because you called the cops on me and
you don't talk to me
maybe our relationship isn't real are
you mad at me
and you've never spoken to me yeah i'm
getting mixed signals here babe i don't
wanna
make like a whole thing of that also
write me this
with this this nice picture here because
you have to log it all whenever it
becomes like a police report so there's
a nice little sort of yeah picture
situation here oh yeah i love that and
it says
heavenly summer a marriage stars
aligning enjoy the games
okay i love that he always like am i
taking my anti-delusion pills what was
it yeah shaking a handful of skittles
and throwing them back i feel like my
anti-delusion pills aren't working
it's like it has an altoids
[Music]
it's like talking to a sock puppet on
your hand that is speaking in some coded
backward language and i've been talking
to that hand puppet for two years and
made no further progress in furthering
our relationship
that's so he's kind of strangely
accurate because i
never spoke to you and you thought my
tweets were all directed at you that's
my absolutely
that's bad
yeah that's pretty bad that's actually
bad yeah the whole thing is pretty bad
some of them are
some of these are wild um like there
were emails that were like let me know
if you want me to start cleaning out the
bedroom area so you can come and move in
no yeah that's just like that yeah yeah
honestly um
you know like when i was thinking about
going through your unrequited dm's i
didn't think that there would be someone
in there
that would actually believe that you're
in a relationship with them several
this this is one of the worst ones in
that like all of his liked videos on
youtube were like how to breach and
enter a building he's ex-military oh my
god yeah he was ex-military and oh of
course admitted to open carrying in l.a
yeah and you're wearing lips because he
sent me his address because he was upset
that i hadn't moved in yet yeah okay so
good that you called the cop yeah your
sock puppet girlfriend you know that
what is some song this isn't i mean
again this is all actually pretty
seriously [ __ ] up but this is another
one that was pretty exciting is um he
sent me a relationship deadline and it
was that if i didn't respond to him by a
certain point in time he was ending the
relationship he went back on it i didn't
reply and he was like i'm back you went
back never mind relationship you called
my bluff you got i'm not gonna break oh
and pierce okay the reason
are as followed in order of importance
your communication style seems crazy
it's like i'm talking to myself
you were
you are b i think sometimes to myself
that i'm an obsessive superfan and
others who look at my social media
probably think that
too my mom thinks so whenever you
mention stalkers sometimes they think
maybe i'm a stalker as well
just getting up against it
brushing the cheek with his cheeks
two butts just rubbing up in the night
the length of time i've been courting
you almost a year now excluding the four
years i've been following you on youtube
which encountered a statement we're back
i think one or two attempts if no
replies are normal to stop pursuing and
so yeah he sent me um
there's also an email that says can you
reply to me on a social network so
people don't think i'm stalking you they
may already think i'm weird for pursuing
you when you don't reply but the fact
that you never respond to me anywhere is
starting to look pretty weird and i want
people to know what real
what worrying about his his image and
why he looks god
never spoke to him god he didn't have a
person though so i spoke to him in
person and like the first time he did i
didn't know that he had also sent me 400
emails and he gave me a necklace and i
was like thank you
sir
must have fueled him for two years yeah
i think he thought it was a date
he just showed up at e3 while i was
working and then got mad because my
producer at e3 had to pull me away from
anyone i was talking to him was like you
have to go back on stage and so he sent
this email about how much he hated my
live producer
and i was like zach you may get murdered
when i saw all these emails i was like
yeah yeah yeah yeah he may kill you i i
don't i didn't know any of this was
happening
mostly my emails dudes trying to nag me
oh my dms yes yeah yeah i bet yeah i
don't read a lot of it a lot of necks a
lot of just like a lot of necks and
finally you like lost weight or whatever
like it's just a lot of that really okay
yeah
i got i got a comment a couple months
ago on
twitter that was like about uh the bangs
are not a good look
but then they ended it with like don't
mind me though i'm just actually perving
so they admitted to the neg in the neck
an interesting strategy what
but they were but they were perving so
it was like you'd look better without
the fringe is what they said
and then they said don't mind me i'm
just actually perving or something is it
because they would like to see more of
your face they're like get that hair off
that girl i want to see the whole
people i i think i posted the screenshot
i was like damn my man's trying to get
that
wild it was it was so per actually
perving it just sticks in my craw hold
on here we go yeah oh no it was a
youtube comment i look good this day by
the way the bangs are done
carl
uh said
charlotte would look better without the
fringe i'm not hating i'm actually
perving and then an emoji with a zipper
mouth
i'm not hating
i'm actually perving
so again i think that not advanced to
see more of your face
that's all there's so much in my face
you can actually see my ear is like
parted through this side
it's not an idea
and then and then somebody responded to
this screenshot
right so i screenshotted this and put
out charlotte would look better without
the fringe i'm not hating him actually
perving
and then
francis replied
i have an opinion on this but it doesn't
matter you do you
and i responded and i said why would you
still tell me this
princess and then francis replies you're
absolutely right missed an opportunity
to shut up
well that's nice of francis francis in
the end
uh francis had an owl but came
yeah
i'm still mad about the initial yeah
that's right right but i'm not hating
i'm actually perfect
the thing that gets me about this is
that i always just want to be like who
are these people
in that
i don't know anyone who would write [ __ ]
like that on the i don't leave youtube
comments at all i don't always drive i i
would never all the time
i had leaves a youtube comment and if
you are commenting under this who are
you and also thanks for being here we
really appreciate you as part of us
we mean the weirdos it's i guess like
the only thing that i can understand is
if i don't like something like if i
don't care for something if i have it i
legitimately
move on with my life i do not even leave
there would be no chance that i leave a
comment there would be no chance that i
leave any type of thing about
so if i like something i tend to want to
support it yeah so i will leave a
comment i will like i will upvote
whatever
but
to write something negative
is so baffling to me because i'm like it
doesn't affect me at all i feel like if
i knew somebody who was doing it i would
understand it more but i do not think a
single human i know operates that way i
have no one i have not met in person
anyone who has left a a [ __ ]
comment i have a youtube video
they have yeah who are they which one is
it it's elise williams
it's elise
she's just perfect no francis is just an
uh ancillary uh
yeah
who i guess did recover in some way no i
think that may be my standard like just
too low that when i get an apology from
somebody
i'm like oh yeah oh thank you yeah the
bar is very low so we were actually
impressed that
you're right
you're right patrick has pointed out
that people don't expect me to be mean
to them
online i see
like people i
yeah i don't expect you to be mean that
is true
i wonder why i was mean to someone last
night they unfollowed me
nice
yeah get it out you know awesome
yeah just just get out of here
as someone who is neurodivergent i am
unintentionally mean
all the time and actually have no idea
that i'm being mean uh very frequent
probably my single biggest issue with
like being a content creator is that i
say something that i think is a fact and
people go wow that was really rude and
i'm like i think i just wrote a literal
fact
i
all the time
right no
then people go oh sorry i upset you and
i go
i just said no i answered the question
with a fact
no right and then maybe they all the
time and it's very very difficult i do
not understand it at all i think maybe
people who aren't urid ever
neurodivergent just read things
with emotion or everything they write
has emotion in it and i'm like so
i think that's also a very american
thing too because maybe
something about it
but the thing was like that was
something i had to kind of get used to
is that in america everyone's kind of
fake nice yeah
yeah and then in europe and then i know
like people in america think like
french people or like italian people are
very snobby which fair there might be
some things there but sometimes it's
just because they don't
care yeah they don't just like you know
they're like they just don't they just
do away with the superficial yes they
don't do the superficial thing like they
don't
you know do that stuff yeah i think no
australians don't either like that's
something i've noticed americans are
very fake nice but like it is more of a
problem on the internet
oh yeah anything like all the time
people like i don't understand why you
being so rude and i'm like i didn't
think anything i just said was rude
at all yeah
okay
people are upset they're like because i
just go no full stop as an answer to a
question because i'm like it's quick and
it's efficient and they go wow i'm
really sorry i even asked i want no with
a period yeah but it again it might it's
and i recognize that people find it
offensive but because i don't understand
why they find it offensive i can't stop
should i do no smiley face
no no no no i would just say the period
just maybe the period makes it
rude the period
adds a finality to the no yeah this
happens like this is in texting too
people don't like
well i'm not saying it's rude i'm on
your side i appreciate that i'm not
trying to defend these people francis's
of the world the franchise yeah but
we don't like
text at least on the american end of it
we don't like carl carl can curve
off period conveys a finality in a
certain way yeah it's like how patrick
uses lowercase's lowercase k as a as
just a regular like text to send
right it took me a little bit because i
thought he would be mad at me but
patrick doesn't
think that much it's a 48 year old
white man texts as a 48 yeah he's gonna
have to go next year
but yeah i mean this is
i worry a lot about the way i come off
in text as someone who reads a lot into
texts
uh and will keep reading into text and
so i think there's been a lot of meaning
imbued by
final punctuation and
i should try and change it the problem
is just when i con i've read it i've
read about it but it's it's not just me
well i also
i think you should keep doing the period
too though because like do you it
doesn't mean and sometimes i just say
okay
and when i say okay i mean yeah okay
that people go whoa
and i go i just meant it was okay and
it's very again i just don't understand
why i can't say okay
i see i i just i just need to tell
everyone a content creator is not mad at
you they're not thinking about you
also a content creator has moved on if
there are a hundred of you i can't write
no comma sentence explaining the no
smiley face a thousand times like it
it's just more efficient for me to say
just know
that's what it is i just have to get my
no out i answered your question
move on gotta get your nose out yeah i
don't have to chat with calls like you
know yeah i don't know
i think i think you should keep actually
now it should just be your signature no
no yeah no at every time
so people given when i missed you guys
yeah
really looking forward to this
um speaking of us responding to things
we did get some tinder bio submissions
from the listeners
oh hell yeah
the first one here i'm gonna not show
you the way these look i will show the
people at home but not show you all so
that it yeah you know less impacted okay
another drill
okay
first i've been here before
honor student research assistant
don't need to give any more of that
information i don't think uh about me
animal ecology student ask me your
animal questions love all animals but
fish and aquatic life in particular tv
slash gaming binger nature lover cheeky
red flags but i'm worth it promise no
kids i've traveled a bit but not enough
plant-based but i don't judge 6-4
non-smoker looking for conversations
friendship flirting plus fun open to
something more serious
and then they share their snap
friend emoji for her i don't know what
the rest of this means um
so i think starting with
animal oncology student ask me your
animal questions
is great
that's good that is good
personally
i think the choice to put six foot four
at the very bottom
is also good because from my
understanding a lot of these people just
put their height and that's it yes you
didn't you didn't over enter it's valid
it's valid to put that that there i
guess red flags but i'm worth it promise
feels like a red flag
that's a red flag and also that's not
good
there was a lot of information that i
feel like didn't really need to be said
i've traveled a bit but not enough of it
already
you what
i've traveled a bit but not i just i
think it went
well and i forgot most of the bio the
second i can't even show it to you
easily anyway so it is what it is yeah
oh no no i'm it is what it is i'm just
saying that it was so much too much
information that it just washed over me
and i'm just like okay so they don't
smoke and they don't right i think there
was just too much
too long too much too long
too long is this a tinder bio
this is a tinder buyer
ooh
you don't need to put no kids in a
tinder bar you don't you that's uh that
was awesome
you don't have to put a lot of that
information in a tinder so what do you
think it does need
like i again i like animal ecology
students ask me your animal questions
yeah the animals is fine and i think
that should have been a wrap like maybe
even a plant-based is fine too because
that's like a good conversation starter
as well but everything else too much
too much
oh like plant-based diet is that what
they say they just said plant-based but
i don't judge which makes me assume that
they're saying
that oh yeah i think that it's good to
say i don't know that is also something
that would come up no i think that
well i think that factors into my
swiping is like yeah i'm not vegan yeah
and i like to enjoy food is really
important to me and i like to enjoy
the similar foods with people that i'm
dating yeah like i don't i don't i don't
begrudge anyone for being vegan or
vegetarian
but
i
you just want to know
with people and i and i want to cook for
people i just want to have a dad i have
a damn good yeah
uh that that's important to me for
dating i think we're thinking short-term
dating information that's important that
is important that's why i think that
could have stayed
i genuinely everything else
i don't think they did all right
everyone has red flags you don't need to
tell us you have them because that in
itself is arrested we've all got them
yeah yeah yeah okay just understand that
you're flawed that's good you don't have
to wear it on your sleeve yeah exactly
it's hard not to okay
the next one
uh you're saying something about me are
you saying stop thinking
the next one is very short
currently romantic asexual artist love
listening conversation cuddling
i think leading with currently romantic
asexual is important
to any potential suitors i think that is
an important thing to note
yeah yeah and shouts out to the ace
babes
shout out in the listenership and the
chat and the in the artists love
listening conversation cuddling i
actually think that this probably would
work quite well for the exact people you
are trying to attract you are not going
to get a ton of engagement on this but
for the people that you actually want to
engage
yeah i think you're good
yeah i think it's good
yeah i mean this person does also have a
profile picture on there that i think is
very nice picture
um okay good okay
but are they how tall are they and do
they smoke
how many red flags
about and are you worth it anyway
promise if you didn't think you were
worth it i feel like you wouldn't be on
tandem
no that's not true no no no worth it
you don't want any part of this
i'm a mess i'm a disaster
what is it keep walking if you value
yourself what does it mean when people
are verified
uh it's it's like it's yeah
it's yeah you're just a real person like
it's just it just just sends you a
message as you check your emails
it's not like it's not like twitter
you've showed your license i think do
you have to like show i id
i think it's like just like a phone and
email verification like it's it's pretty
light like it probably could be spoofed
by a robot or whatever or a fake account
but it's it's i think also like some
some of them actually like look at your
picture
okay yeah i also want to know at this
point in the podcast
charlotte's microphone may be completely
fine it may also be crackly and we're
aware of it i don't know what's going to
come out on the recording i can still
hear it i don't know if you at home can
hear it if you can shut up
i think it's fine we're sorry i think
it's fine i think it's fine looking at
audition okay
then hey i do apologize i'm sorry i i
it's actually not annoying to me at all
but if you don't address it people will
say crackly audio and if you do address
it they will not mention it
it would annoy me as a listener
would i say something on youtube no
because i've never left a youtube
comment
okay
this one
his first picture is
has a little vaccinated sticker on it
which i actually think is not a bad idea
okay okay um okay
okay we'll get i'm getting all the
pictures at first which i can't show you
so the
the about me is
i'm not a good singer but i'm very very
good at karaoke
i like i guess
yeah
let's sit and debate which is better
pizza or
cheeseburger both in emoji form
i like to compare myself to robin
williams i am a kid at heart like in
hook i'll make a wish come true like the
genie i'll probably end up killing
myself one day
okay whoa okay so
i didn't read these in advance yeah yeah
so wait hold on okay so that okay took a
turn i understand the the kind of
goofiness and the the lighthearted thing
but
into the
kill yourself but the thing that blew my
mind
was again these bios need to be short
and specially if you're going for a joke
i think you got to pick one and this is
you need to pick one
it should have stopped at burger
cheeseburger pizza and that's it
honestly so there's another one that i
he also says for what it's worth i've
never listened to the joe rogan podcast
i like that that's good maybe that
should be a finisher
that should have been a finisher after
the cheeseburger pizza and then i'm six
foot tall and can't dunk a basketball
yet um so if you want to mention the
height because they say it's important i
just put six foot four
yeah just put six foot um
i can understand why you're going for
this robin williams joke potentially if
you're looking for again a very specific
kind of person my reaction was genuine
as i read this and i just got it
oh i get the joke
right oh i get it if if he were going to
do the joke the format should have been
child like hook something like the genie
kill myself like
like or and then maybe like make the
joke trailing off and going actually
never mind like if the joke did that
would have been better yeah the the
structure of the joke is off and wrong
the joke didn't need to happen this is
too much personality in a bi
if that's like yeah if that's like a
thing you like dark jokes that's
something you can do in chat privately
and true but it didn't even land it
wasn't even a welcome question
again
that's what's getting me please submit
jokes on the email
we'll get back to you i'll oh yeah i'll
i think i have your jokes edit this too
i'm not a good singer but i'm very very
good at karaoke i think that's exciting
and for what it's worth i've never
listened to the joe rogan podcast
i think so and the basketball you don't
even need the cheese cheeseburger yeah
you can you like the like foot
you can keep that you can cheeseburger
pizza that's just [ __ ] that's my
issue [ __ ] i agree cheeseburger pizza is
too basic
it is too basic
i just thought maybe that's like a
conversation starter
yeah probably there are some basic girls
who
who love that kind of debate oh my god i
love pizza but my friend jessica loves
cheeseburgers that's actually
i actually can't eat cheeseburger
because i'm lactose i but i eat cheese
anyways no
oh my god i'm so sorry my dad was
lactose he still is i'm not he still is
is he dead
yeah but he's
intolerant well
not if he eats
cheese or has a lot of dairy he could
die
he could die if he could die it's
literally the saddest thing i've ever
heard no
you have such a tough life
i just i just wish i could find like
crazy
yeah someone's like super funny
like robin williams
oh no my favorite movie is laden
my favorite movie is bicentennial man
do you remember that week where rooster
teeth just wouldn't stop
tweeting about the lasagnas
oh yeah i already lasagnased
yeah it was a lot yeah it was just a lot
of tweets about you know what they had
they had them
they had a moment yeah
lasagna or stuffed shell or lasagna
lasagna is good stuff shells pretty good
too yeah they're lactose intolerant
i don't want to make like a stir up any
trouble but i don't think i can come to
class today i just found out i mocked it
so taller
this is invaluable information judge me
accordingly tell me not to do it i keep
doing it um good no judge not lest you
[ __ ] yourself wow that was oh you should
write the poem for that guy oh yeah that
guy yeah yeah yeah something that they
definitely are kissing and the two butts
touching i don't know it's been so long
you know
okay something about butts touching i
don't know hey fiona do you think
there's like gay lasagna that we could
call like lasagna
lasagna yeah it's just when a bunch of
lesbians lay on top of each other
oh
[Laughter]
is
oat milk shouts out oatley you have a
bad ad campaign but only is good
oatley's the jam yeah i actually do like
oatmeal quite a bit also yeah
i mean i prefer almond milk but it's
ruining the california water table
oh no
that is maybe water table is the wrong
fact uh i don't know but
almond almond farming using a ton of
water
really yeah apparently yeah
we're in a drought even
yeah well but we have a lot of almonds
that's i want you to march down to the
nearest cafe [ __ ] it
i'd burn it all down for an almond milk
apparently
all right we're gonna go one more before
we wrap up the show okay
okay okay this has a preamble
okay
okay
[Laughter]
me another tinder bio i am ready to go
ready okay i did you do cheer too
i did not ah you did cheer too
did you
yes on ironically
tinder bio
cinderella i just found out that i'm in
marching band
it's so sad
this one has a preamble i don't
particularly stand out on tinder and
rely on humor when meeting people which
is very hard to get across at a profile
after having many fruitless normal
accounts with nice pictures and a bio of
interest and stuff i decided to make an
anti-tinder account i wanted to try and
do all the regular tinder faux pas and
subvert them this profile is more just
for fun i was curious to see the
response
i did get a match and almost got a
relationship from it
um okay so the pictures are one of them
as a kid there's one of them oh that
preamble was the person who sent it yes
wait that was the it's their opinion
it's them explaining the bible okay okay
okay
i totally was in the wrong frame of mind
yeah okay what did you think that was oh
you thought that was the best i thought
that was the bio i thought was part of
the bible
oh no i thought
um
okay it says i have a group photo where
it isn't difficult to see which one i am
i have a photo that is out of date and i
don't look like that anymore i have a
bottomless selfie instead of a topless
one and then i'm posing with my sweet
wheels i don't like hiking travel or
movies i also don't like netflix music
or stuff
my guess is this is all parodies of
things people do on tinder
and i don't have the expertise to be
familiar with that and they are true
there this picture of them on the bike
the with their car
is uh them posing
very seductively on a um lawnmower which
is actually a very good picture that is
that's pretty funny
and then the group photo they're
referring to it says i have a group
photo where it's not difficult to tell
which one i am
is uh one two three four five six
versions of them edited into the same
picture
okay also quite cool this is a very
visual gag
yes the photo where they say is not
shirtless is literally them without
pants on with a little like black bar
covering their privates but wearing a
full hoodie up the top yeah again
clearly also a joke and then there is
just a picture of them like looking
handsome at a ball and pictured them as
a kid
so i think that the
the pictures
fantastic i wouldn't explain them
because i think the explanation in the
bio comes across as a little bit like
two like better than everybody else
yeah yeah
what's the what's the bio i have a group
photo where it isn't difficult to see
which one i am i have a photo explaining
it okay yeah it's a good bit it is a
good bit i think that you would get
some witty
people if you
didn't explain the bits
i agree
i don't know the pictures are good
yeah pictures of the one picture in
particular sounds like a really good one
to start with it's it's a very good
picture yeah
it i mean i think that would that would
stay my thumb
yeah it's good
what do you mean that would stay her
like a sword like you know you don't
kill someone you stay your sword i see
okay
i would i would stay my again
we have somebody on this podcast who was
in band
marching band
what's happened to you yeah and that
that bestows upon a person a fair a fair
degree of eloquence sure yeah and
definitely not just a bonafide weirdo
generator oh that's that's what i meant
oh okay
looking for a walking partner
only walking
looking for a marching partner
look i put 25 to 45
seeking f
medium height
27 green eyes
cheetah and cougar cheetah and
links and jungle cat
licks and jungle no sail
no zoo
no zoo
submissions everybody you can submit
again it is rloc submissions gmail.com
i'm not going to put it in the
description again because it means that
we get a bunch of spam apparently
um
so you just have to remember rloc
submissions at gmail.com there are some
more that we didn't get to but i'm also
cool with uh dating advice
you need to answer some questions for
you
that's great we got yeah
we got it
and if you're feeling sick after
drinking a glass of whole milk maybe
you're
lactose you're definitely lactose and i
would recommend
some oatmeal
there's also a thing and i like to crack
you out of the trash
yeah lactate
well actually it does work too actually
[Laughter]
lactose intolerant but don't judge um
thank you all for listening
worth it
uh charlotte what are you up to is there
anything you would like to promote
oh boy um
so uh go uh check out what a show listen
to mom's home
on spotify apple music wherever you get
your tunes
uh yeah those two those two are the
biggins fiona how about you
um
you could find me on instagram and
twitter at fiona nova
and uh i feel like by that time that by
the time this episode releases i think
i'll actually have a kickstarter
happening for my next short film
exciting yeah i can leave link in the
description that's awesome yeah i'll let
you know i'm i'm hoping by the time this
comes out it'll be out but if that isn't
the case i will this will be out help
next monday
next monday it probably will be
announced at that time but it is not you
won't be able to donate just yet you'll
be able to like
follow the think about it okay yeah
you'll be able to like follow the
project on kickstarter get your finances
see what's happening yes yeah keep that
in mind i'll leave a link in the
description yes to both to all to all of
those things thank you everybody for
watching yeah thank you love you guys
thank you
thank you
thank you so much for watching this
podcast
we'll see you next time oh my god i hate
it so much
how is she still going close your mouth
oh god
my
[Music]
i'm